préviens-moi est-ce que vous êtes
guillaume Bats
[Musique]
quand je pense qu'il y a des gens qui
ont handicapé dans leur famille et qui
vont jamais les voix
alors payez pour avoir un qu'on connait
pas
parce que c'était pas gagné pour moi
[Applaudissements]
bien écouter on peut continuer dans un
esprit de convivialité de joie je me
présente je m'appelle Goldman c'est la
maladie des ovaires et je suis 27
fracture
impressionnant ce qui fait de moi madame
monsieur le champion national de
fracture postale
[Applaudissements]
question sur laquelle je vais répondre
tout de suite pour crever l'abcès j'y
réponds moi-même parce que je sais pas
l'expérience que tout le monde se pose
la question oui ma est droite
[Applaudissements]
Facebook en général vers février mars où
vous écrivez je me suis cassé le poignet
vous le régler mes skis
parce que le jour où vous arriverez à
vous faire 27 fractures au sport d'hiver
vous m'appellerez le seul qui a essayé
espèce de sur trois fois par jour et
bague de ma torchoir en fixant avec
nostalgie c'est trop cette formule 1 tu
vois donc
[Musique]
vous savez que la première chose que les
médecins
passera pas la nuit le petit et là toute
ma famille est partie de l'hôpital ils
ont foncé à l'église ils se sont mis à
genoux ils ont les médailles ils ont un
peu Reggio toute la nuit et malgré leur
prière
j'ai survécu
[Applaudissements]
alors
maladie des advers scientifiquement
appelé aussi
ostéogenèse imparfaites
c'est vrai que quand tu vois le résultat
[Musique]
et c'est marrant parce que depuis j'ai
fait quelques passages télé il arrive
maintenant de temps en temps que des
gens dans la rue me reconnaissent et les
gens ils sont mignons ils me disent
toujours la même chose excusez-moi
est-ce que vous êtes guillaume Bats
à votre avis
j'ai le temps à la probabilité que vous
croisiez mon sosie
[Applaudissements]
donc soit je suis Guillaume
et j'ai oublié de sortir tu vois que
bon en tout cas aujourd'hui je suis
Maurice mais mon enfin moi j'aimerais
être dans la vie comme tout le monde
fondé une famille je vais avoir des
enfants et j'ai tellement de choses à
leur donner mes enfants
m'a déjà cette maladie qui est génétique
tu vois c'est un patrimoine comme un
autre je suis désolé alors Malaga
maladie génétique oui mais pas forcément
héréditaire mais moi je ferai des
enfants jusqu'à temps qu'il y a un kiné
je suis désolé en plus on dit qu'un
enfant prend physiquement de ses deux
parents ok mais dans ce cas là j'ai
quand même un terrain à me taper un
de top model pour compenser tu
vois que
vous l'avez les mages là
c'est moi qui te le dis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu